This app isn't what it used to be.
And I know I'm not the only one who feels this way,
but some of y'all don't care.
And I think everybody is so frustrated
and angry with the state of the world,
justifiably so, um,
that we have turned this place that was a digital third space
a social media community, and has made it one of the most, like,
toxic places since, I don't know, 2016.
Instagram. The way people will just be outspokenly heinous to people
for the smallest thing. Like,
I have seen some of my mutuals who literally just post their, like,
day to day life
being given death threats because they're so cringe or so annoying.
Like, who the fuck raised you to think that that's okay to say?
Somebody. Or what's happened to Chris Olsen,
which basically, he was, like,
shot up to stardom on this app.
His entire livelihood and, like,
life is based on this app.
And now
we are watching everything about his life be completely destroyed
because, I don't know,
people got bored of him. They got oversaturated.
Elise Myers,
who is arguably one of the most positive forces for good on this app,
getting bullied off the app
because she wouldn't open up her mouth
and talk about a topic you wanted her to talk about and listen.
I get it. It came from a good place.
I am in complete support of the Palestinian cause
and have posted about It on my page,
but my page. I have always spoken about controversial issues.
Elise hasn't. And maybe that's not a good enough excuse for you
to justify her not speaking out.
But you know what you do? You unfollow,
you block. You tell people that you don't appreciate her stance.
You talk.
You don't tell her that she doesn't deserve to have her children
and that she should go on a life herself.
That's fucking unhinged.
There's so many people that are scared to even start making content
because some of y'all are just so fucking mean.
And I don't know,
I remember when this place was, like,
a really wonderful community for people during COVID,
when we didn't have places to, like,
congregate, to have conversations,
to hang out with other people.
This was that place. At least it was for me.
Like, good creativity is not going to exist under these conditions,
because people aren't gonna put themselves out there to be torn apart
for the sound of their voice,
their appearance. God forbid they, like,
try to do something that they aren't fucking perfect at on this app.
God forbid they, like,
ask advice about something
and get told that they look like fucking shit
and should just not even try.
There's always been trolls,
and I get that, but it's insanely worse than it used to be,
and it's just. It's really sad.